en una tienda tienen cuatro marcas de
pesticidas cada uno tiene diferentes
concentraciones y también tiene
diferente tamaño de botella tenemos esas
cuatro marcas
abc de tenemos el tamaño de las botellas
en mililitros o en litros
tenemos la concentración que es el
porcentaje del volumen de fluido que
corresponde al pesticida y el precio por
botella si se quiere tener más
ingrediente activo por lo que se paga se
debe comprar la botella de la marca aquí
tenemos que elegir los invito a que
pausa en el vídeo y piensen en ello
tenemos que pensar en la cantidad de el
ingrediente activo ingrediente activo
por botella
en mililitros
en este primer caso tenemos 375
mililitros de la botella y el 65% de
concentración el 65% de 375 nos da 375 x
0.65 igual a 243 puntos 75 son 243
puntos 75 mililitros mililitros por
botella es importante que conservemos
las unidades por botella cuál será el
ingrediente activo por dólar
bueno pues tenemos esta cantidad la
vamos a dividir entre el precio es 243
puntos 75 entre 22 usamos lo que tenemos
en la calculadora y esto lo dividimos
entre 22 nos da 11.07 11.07
mililitros por dólar
otra forma de pensar en ello es que si
tengo 243 puntos 75 mililitros por
botella y quiero llegar a algo que tenga
mililitros por dólar pues a esto lo voy
a tener que multiplicar por algo que
tenga bueno quiero deshacerme de las
botellas aquí en el denominador así que
va a ser algo que tenga botella en el
numerador y tenga dólar en el
denominador así con el análisis
dimensional yo puedo quitar estas
unidades de botella y me quedan
mililitros por dólar que es lo que busco
y cuántas botellas hay en un dólar bueno
suena media extraña la pregunta otra
forma de pensar en ello es que una
botella una botella cuesta 22 dólares
así que multiplicamos 240 y 3.75 por 1
entre 22 o dividimos 243 puntos 75 entre
22 y nos da esta cantidad de que le voy
a recorrer para tener el espacio para
escribir la cantidad numérica y quedamos
que son 11 puntos 0 7
y tres por dos ya que aquí cancelamos
las botellas y nos quedan las unidades
de mililitro por dólar aquí podemos
aplicar el sentido común esto es lo que
tenemos en una botella que cuesta 22
dólares por lo que dividimos esto entre
22 y así obtenemos los mililitros por
dólar
vamos a hacer esto para todas las demás
opciones de marcas este es el primero el
siguiente es 750 mililitros y la
concentración es del 35% multiplicamos
750 por 35% iguala 262.5 mililitros por
botella
y esto lo dividimos entre el costo que
es 21 entre 21 y nos da 12.5 mililitros
por dólar
litros por dólar la siguiente tenemos
aquí un litro no mililitros pero sabemos
que un litro es igual a mil mililitros y
el 75 por ciento de 1000 va a ser igual
a 750 mililitros por botella y estos 750
lo dividimos entre el costo de 68
dólares de 68 dólares 750 entre 68
11.029 redondeamos a 11 dólares con tres
centavos mililitros por dólar finalmente
tenemos la marca de que son 1.5 litros o
lo que es lo mismo mil 500 mililitros un
litro es igual a mil mililitros litro y
medio va a ser igual a mil más 500 mil
500 mililitros al 30% el 30% de mil 500
mililitros son 450 mililitros 450
litros por botella y si esto lo
dividimos entre 40 450 entre 40 nos da
11.25 nos da 11.25 mililitros por dólar
cuál es la mejor opción pues es la que
tenga más mililitros por dólar
vemos de estas cuatro opciones es
nuestra opción b o la marca b nuestra
respuesta es la opción b